[Music]
good morning Hank it's Wednesday March
21st I assume you don't want to look at
my eye for the next three minutes so
let's find something else to do first
we're going to look at these beautiful
pictures that the guide shot inside the
abandoned Cathedral I mean Theatre in
Detroit they do a much better job of
showing what it was like to be inside
than the video does thanks to the guide
at Essen web org for these pictures and
finally Hank I've been thinking of what
you should do when you've had a long day
that's kind of been bad and your eye
hurts and sweepy and gross and no one
wants to be near you and everyone looks
at you funny and it seems to me that the
answer is simple you just take stuff and
you put it on your head wait where's the
camera
where am I put it on your head when
you're sad and you've got pinkeye the
world seems rough and suck levels are
high just remember there's one thing
that you can do and it always works too
you got to put stuff on your head
put stuff on your head well it can be
blue or it can be red the color doesn't
matter if it's on your head
attach a photo with woody right onto
your melon or a fix a Christmas stocking
to your cerebellum the only rule of
thumb is don't use a plastic bag cuz
that could go really wrong you got to
put stuff on your head put stuff on your
head well it could be blue or it could
be red the color doesn't matter if it's
on your head Thank You New York what's
on your head Hank I'll see you tomorrow